hi I'm Erik Bosse and I'm Philip Malina
and after spending so much time
obsessing over and analyzing the world
of Star Wars in our videos in this video
we're gonna do something special we're
gonna analyze and explain the fighting
styles of some of the best fighters and
Star Wars by actually battling Sith
Lords Lenovo actually partnered with us
and sent us the Star Wars Jedi
challenges device which lets you train
to be a Jedi in augmented reality in
this experience we get to hold an
authentic lightsaber in our hands and
battle Sith Lords like Darth Vader in
your home or our studio the game story
is actually modeled after the real
training methods that we've since
learned exist within the Star Wars story
itself and along the way you're
developing the necessary skills to
become a Jedi which is why there are
also like alternate experiences in there
for instance strategic combat well
there's a little tiny scrag ler
annihilate him you can also work on the
rest of your brain like chewy and
Threepio do with hollow chess I guess
like my favorite game of DiGeorge let's
go ahead into some boxes and give a
quick rundown of how it all works
you ready yeah II made a my face what
that's legit
this just very easily pops open oh cool
so you put your phone in there
so it is based on your smartphone you
plug in a smartphone into the headset
that it comes with what do you see
everything's different everything's
better this beacon is actually kind of
like an artifact holocron that we
discovered and we get to use it as a
training device that contains the
archivist who walks us through the
training to become a Jedi you actually
end up fighting virtual recordings of
various characters in their fighting
styles or we know from the movies now
Before we jump in and just play this
since we here at new rock stars like to
dig deeper into the real world
influences on the Star Wars universe
we're gonna do what any nerds who are
nervous about a fight would do and we're
gonna try to get ready for the fight you
brains ah basically we're gonna analyze
the specific lightsaber fighting styles
that are sit deponents are gonna use and
we've actually hired a real expert
swordsman to help define those
techniques and explain to us what
defenses we should use and also how to
counter attack alright so let's go meet
our friend Ken mercs thank you for
joining us sword fighting expert yes
well thank you for having me appreciate
you guys have me into your dojo so what
we're basically trying to do is we know
we're gonna get our asses handed to us
by these six expert badasses and we
don't want to lose too terribly so we're
gonna have you help us we're also gonna
study and analyze the actual fighting
styles of these characters use starting
with Darth Vader
so Darth Vader uses the fighting style
known as Mikasa
it's form two of the seven different
forms of lightsaber fighting and it's
actually pretty straightforward it
emphasizes precision simple footwork and
preventing disarmament but how does that
actually translate to the real world and
our actual fighting style well his
fighting style and many of the original
timeline Star Wars lightsaber duels were
actually inspired by the Japanese
martial art of kendo which was a style
seen in classic samurai films by Akira
Kurosawa which George Lucas mentioned as
a major inspiration so let's see how
that actually works and then the kendo
of the economy of movement and the force
and the power behind the strokes that he
has so it's an it's a really interesting
combination of styles but generally he's
wielding his saber as a broadsword and
how would you defend yourself against
that so we use deceptions so when you
see that big wind up and strike you just
drop or raise the blade or the the saber
so it doesn't get struck out of the way
so that pattern with leg head shoulder
and again leg head shoulder now because
I'm emphasizing the strokes that gives
you openings exactly I didn't want to do
it but I could've killed you if you
could have killed me as I go to your leg
and I wind up there's your yeah you
strike me right in the ribs and that
would have changed the whole course of
the galaxy or ruined your day okay so if
I go leg head and I could pick that up
and then there could be a dishonor
[Applause]
[Music]
you killed both of us
so I think it's speed over power okay I
feel like I could beat up Darth Vader
now like I think we got it all right
Vader here I come
oh crap he's look so pissed he just
floats toward me Perry Perry Perry
repost winding up
[Music]
[Music]
that again up next I think we're really
curious about the fighting style that
Darth Maul uses that's right and because
it was in the prequels it kind of
changed up some of the fighting styles
so let's look deeper at some of the
different ways that a Darth Maul fights
differently from Vader
okay in the Star Wars universe Darth
Maul uses Niemann form 6 which combines
all kinds of Star Wars universe fighting
forms but with added force techniques
like force pushes it's also common for a
dual wield lightsabers Darth Maul
actually also uses form 7 which is juje
or pod maybe it channels emotion into
chaotic and really unpredictable moves
that keep your opponent's constantly off
their guard in the real world
those flashier styles are probably
rooted in maybe Chinese fighting styles
but if you're thinking about what about
all those flips and stuff actually ray
Park the actor brought those in himself
flips and gymnastics in general that
aren't really terribly realistic to the
actual fighting styles that one would
probably is
yeah and that's because a lot of those
flip moves would probably leave Darth
Maul or qui-gon or obi-wan totally open
for easy strikes meklin oh that was a
big mistake his movements and his
acrobatics really remind me of wushu and
that kind of low to the ground very
athletic very fast lots of spinning
which means you have these two blades
constantly kind of creating a barrier
give it a try
so we're looking for weaknesses in Darth
Maul's technique right so say in order
to cut to my leg you're like he comes in
without spinning the fan you only had
one side you cut to my leg
all right a spin to dead how'd I do
show her no mercy I already killed him
okay
oh okay he's just huh he's trying to
distract you you're gonna open them be
he's being flashy get WIC oh okay okay
almost like I'm intimidated I'm
intimidated don't be intimidated okay
yeah I got hey hey all right I think
we've got our small down now for the
time for us to move on to the most
recent addition to the Star Wars
universe
it's right kylo Ren so kylo Ren actually
has a very different lightsaber which is
pretty obvious but he also has a very
different fighting style than we've ever
seen in Star Wars before so it actually
might seem unusual but within their
universe it makes a lot of sense gotta
remember that Luke who trained kylo
already was the last Jedi and all the
others that were around were pretty much
wiped out so Luke himself wasn't
incredibly well versed in the different
Star Wars lightsaber fighting styles so
Kyle Lohse training probably had a lot
to do with just what techniques worked
for Luke and that means it probably more
resembles a combination of all sorts of
fighting styles from Jedi training so
now when we try to look for a real-world
equivalent it's tough because he uses so
many different techniques in fact the
cross guard on kylo sabor even makes it
so some of his moves are more associated
with medieval swords but similar Hills
to that than anything we've ever seen in
Star Wars yeah so basically it's pretty
unpredictable but still pretty effective
the style that kylo ren's using is is
kind of a wild style and it's not the
most discipline so you think of the
advancement of his weapon he now has a
cross guard or a hilt and your hands are
protected by that cost cross garden you
think of the epidemic and all the other
movies of people losing their hands yeah
finally his style is kind of a mixture
of a broadsword and even almost a
Cutlass like like a pirate would use so
what do you think is the best way to
defend against that type of sword
fighting you look in the movie and you
see the style that Rey uses
it's more point work there's a term in
in fencing call the flesh which
translates to arrow so it's like you use
your body as an arrow and you launch
yourself it's just nice other side boom
here it comes get out of the way boom
and walk away all right well I feel like
we've mastered as much as we can we have
about as much training as Lucas yeah so
let's go for it there he is flashy how
about that how about that
Perry
just the tip just the tip oh man he's
wild styling me the arrow I got him and
I push him back bless bless he bless
bless she flesh flesh Ken what do I do
he's overwhelming me take advantage of
your opponent's weaknesses parry repost
why beat the traffic one more time
your grandpa beat up on me Oh oh crap
that works so well Perry Perry Perry the
tip Perry
oh man don't worry I he's almost dead
well I won you know surprisingly easy no
put my mind to it guys
we really want to thank Lenovo for
creating Jedi challenges but mostly the
opportunity that they are giving
everybody to explore Star Wars from this
like first-person perspective we've
never had that before it's amazing plus
there's also those other fun experiences
that we didn't get to dive into as much
but we're gonna go back into like I'm
all about strategy games actually in
strategy combat so that's what I'm about
to go do yeah and I can't wait to try
out holo chess I've heard it's like this
alright I'm so happy right now anyway
Jedi challenges available now from Best
Buy and if you're watching this from
outside the u.s. check out Jedi
challenges comm for availability in your
area and if you liked watching us do our
version of the Star Wars kid definitely
check out the other creators on YouTube
we'll also did it - thanks so much for
watching bye guys bye